hi folks my name is Alex Sharma I'm a
developer advocate at circle CI and I am
here today to talk to you about
continuous integration which is a
software development practice where
everyone on the engineering team is
continuously integrating these small
code changes back into the codebase
after each change that they're making
there's a suite of tests that runs
automatically that checks the code for
any bugs or errors or anything like that
cool so what does that look like in
practice I've drawn this beautiful flow
chart up here for you step one as you
make it change and this is something
maybe on github you make a future branch
you push it up submit a pull request
that's the change that I'm talking about
here okay push that up then you run your
tests automatically and that's that's
pretty important the tests need to be
run in a consistent way so that everyone
on your team has full confidence that
they're running the tests in the same
way you don't really have a guarantee
that your machine is the same as you
know your neighbors machine that's
that's really hard to to lock down so
those tests are running automatically
somewhere else if they pass right they
pass you're good to go in you can just
keep making changes right you go right
back around submit another floor request
go wild if the tests fail you need to
make sure it's your responsibility to
fix the code okay fix the code until
your tests pass and then you can
continue developing so it's this
wonderful cycle the idea being that you
want to catch these bugs as soon as you
can
right so even if they're not lingering
over a long period of time so that's
what continuous integration is and next
time we'll talk about why you would be
doing this
so today I'm going to talk about why
continuous integration is such a good
thing for you so you might have picked
this up from last time but it's just
safer right the fact that you're running
tests after each little bit of code
means you're gonna catch bugs before
they even happen it's kind of like
Minority Report for software development
think about it that way that's a movie
reference so there's fewer bugs okay
and then there's this wonderful
byproduct of doing proper continuous
integration and the byproduct is that
it's it's hard to continuously integrate
large amounts of code right because
there's more of a chance that you'll get
a merge conflict right the amount of
code if it's small they will probably
agree with each other you can integrate
them but if it's big then you're gonna
have trouble actually doing that on a
regular frequency okay so you're moving
faster you're actually you're making
smaller changes but you're doing them
more often and what that leads is to
more features you're actually able to
make an impact faster you don't have to
wait weeks to actually see your work out
in the real world as long as you're
doing continuous delivery and we'll talk
about that later the second thing is
that you're making better decisions
right because you get your stuff out
into the world faster it means that
you'll be able to figure out whether or
not your users even like what you built
so you might be able to test a theory
more rapidly than you would if you were
taking months right to build an entire
release and so that's kind of the whole
idea is that this iteration speed really
increases the quality of your code not
only is it safer but also it better
matches what people even want because
you have a better understanding of what
people are actually using because of how
quickly you're moving in these small
increments so cool I think that about
does it there's a from a high level
that's kind of like continuous
integration is it's so exciting and
nutritious to software developers
look at this I'm not even on the screen
I'm sharing my screen instead so today
I'm going to show you how to set up a
project from github on circle CI and
we're gonna break a test we're gonna see
it pass and we're gonna move on with our
lives it's gonna be great so the first
thing that you're gonna need is a
project of some kind of github I've
chosen because I'm a little bit biased
circle CI Docs super creative I know
so I forked circle CI Docs and we need
to clone this down so we'll head over
here let's just see where we are good
then we'll clone in here enter your
password don't tell me what it is and
wait depending on your internet speed
and I guess the project size as well
circle CI Docs isn't a traditional web
application it's just a Jekyll blog but
we do have tests and that's really kind
of what we need to get this going
so the one thing I am gonna show you
before we head over to circle CI is the
config file and this is where all the
wonderful stuff is located this is the
single file where you will put the
instructions to Circle C on I on how to
run your build so you'll put in
environment variables you'd put in steps
to actually check out the code restore
dependencies from cache if you have that
you can run very specific commands and
this is really almost infinitely
customizable and we're not actually
going to focus on that today we've got
plenty of documentation on how to set up
good configuration for your projects and
we've actually got some some great
boilerplates and if you're on our
previous version of circle style you can
actually some of these configurations
are actually inferred for you but anyway
don't worry about that all you need to
know is that this is just kind of a list
of instructions and we're gonna see the
names of these steps play out
on the actual build page when we run our
tests so let's let's add the project
here I'm in the circle CI app here I've
already signed up since I work here but
you will have to do that and you'll just
have to authenticate with either github
or your bitbucket account most likely
it's github if you're following this
video so I'm gonna add projects and I
want to build on Linux so let's do that
and here are my my repos on my account
but I want my Fork of a circle CI doc so
let's hit set up project I want to use
the new platform obviously super shiny I
don't think you need to list the
language but let's just put other
because it's mostly just mostly just to
check all things so let's don't worry
about that so now it wants us to it's
telling us create a folder named dot
circle CI and add a file config yeah
well we already have that actually
because I've worked it and we've written
that for circle CI Docs that's that's
already been done for us so we don't
need to do that so let's just start
building right let's just go ahead and
do that and we'll save the hard work of
building a configuration file for
another video I just want to show you
what this actually feels like to use
circle CI so here we have the build is
running we can see when it started so we
can see how long the build is actually
taking to run if you've purchased more
containers depending on your plan you
can run things in parallel so that's
kind of nice and yeah we have an
estimation of the build time this is
really it's really a hopeful stuff at
the top there so let's look at what's
going on this is all part of the test
phase we're spinning up the environment
we're checking out the code we're
storing the cache and you should look
familiar because these are the actual
steps in the configuration of files so I
didn't just lie to you when I said that
we were consuming these steps and then
just performing them
so this is going to take the longest
test with HTML proofer and what this is
doing it's going through and making sure
all the links actually work which is
important for a doc site you don't want
to have broken links scattered
throughout your documentation so this is
our testing phase here and so now I'm
gonna just have to talk a little bit
while we wait for the tests to finish
but what we should see is that build
passes I don't expect any sort of tests
to be failing it actually says it's
passing here but I'm not sure whether
that's inheriting the main circle CI
Doc's build or if it's if it's taking my
fork so we don't actually know so it
looks like all the tests did pass though
we've moved past the HTML [ __ ] phase
and now we're uploading artifacts so
great and I think this is just a copy of
the whole site all right cool so great
we're done you can probably hear my fan
going off and I think that's because I'm
recording my screen my back is angry so
this is fixed this is fixed because I
believe it thought it was broken up
until now because it's inheriting all
the demos I did before this so we have a
green build and that's excellent but
let's break it and see how that works so
say you're going along you're working on
some code in this case it's just
markdown but say you say you just you
remove something and you make a typo and
what we've done here is we've broken
this link so this link will no longer
work because it doesn't have the rest of
the domain name included in this link so
this is an incomplete link and hopefully
our tests will catch that so we will add
this change yep that is what I want
we'll commit this broke a link whoops
and then we'll push this now I'm just
pushing from master to master and
sometimes that can be dangerous in a
production environment but a key part of
continuous integration is committing and
pushing everything into a mainline
branch so we we have to obey that the
rules of the game okay so we just push
this up so now what we should see is or
wait this is gonna be anticlimactic we
don't want to see build eight there
should be a new build starting build
number nine broke a link whoops this is
gonna be really really exciting because
we're gonna see the tests fail okay so
let's just take this time while while
everything is building to talk about why
this is is so so helpful so someone just
made a change and they merged it in
pretty quickly right that wasn't a ton
of work that we just did but within
minutes we're gonna find out that master
is broken and that's really important
because other developers who are
depending on master that relying on
master to actually be correct they won't
be able to branch any new work off of a
unstable mainline branch so this is this
is kind of the crux of why this is so
helpful is you might have this tab open
okay see see how we broke this link so
we we failed the tests here and that's
gonna land us with a failing build
overall so green are steps that have
finished successfully read our steps
that have failed cool so it's failed and
now we need to do what an agent one
should do in this situation which is
fix fix the mistake fix the red-billed
so let's actually just luckily it's in
my undo buffer so I can cheat do that
cool so let's bring the base URL back
let's add this fix the link and then
let's push this back up so I know this
this may be this seems kind of
repetitive but this is the workflow and
in the majority of cases this is kind of
the percentage of time you'll be
spending with circle CI you can just you
can see what changes actually broke the
mainline branch and you can see what
brought it back to normal and this is
really important this is the core part
of continuous integration and the core
part of what circle CI does there's a
very clear version history of one things
went wrong and at what times and how
long it took to build so yeah this is
the takeaway within minutes we knew that
something was wrong and we were able to
respond to it and and that's that's kind
of the nature of the development animal
that were wrangling here is that we want
to catch these things before they become
real problems we want to catch these
small errors before they turn into big
production outages and this is how we do
it we want to keep these times as low as
possible so there's all these other
fancy ways you can increase the speed of
your build and I mentioned parallelism
there's caching there's all sorts of
little tricks that you can use to make
sure that the builds don't take any
longer than they need to and in fact we
could probably be optimizing our own
circle CI Docs it's unclear whether we
need to upload all these right like this
is this is kind of a
costly step right it takes it takes a
big chunk of time so that's another
thing is that you have clarity into
which steps are taking longer than
others and that can help in optimizing
your build time so we're hoping right
that this build past and it looks like
it did so we we fixed it we brought it
back to normal and we just connected a
project from github to circle CI and you
should be very pleased except I don't
know if you were following along
hopefully you were just forking circle
CI Docs as well if you had your own web
application then you probably got hung
up this part because you don't know what
to put in here necessarily but that's
another video for another day and I hope
this gave you kind of a good impression
of what it's like to actually be using
circle CI along with github they work
very nicely together and what you can
actually do is get really cool buttons
like those cool integrations like this I
think if I were to make a pull request
you would also be able to see whether or
not the build was passing the Associated
build is passing and that's it that's a
really great tool for future branches
and pull requests we didn't do that in
this video but you can kind of see how
that would become a big part of your
development workflow
so the last thing we should talk about
is the difference between the three
types of continuous software development
processes we've spent a lot of time on
continuous integration but these are
closely related all these are very
closely related they're often confused
with each other because they aren't so
closely related so just a quick recap of
what continuous integration is all that
is is a software development practice
where you are continuously integrating
your changes into a mainline branch and
the whole purpose of this is to avoid
conflicts it's to avoid surprises by
reducing the size of work that you're
working on and then constantly merging
those in with each other continuous
delivery on the other hand is making
sure that your code that mainline branch
that everyone is merging to is always in
a deployable state so when if you
remember that chart that we did at the
beginning of this series that was
actually sort of a combination of
continuous integration and continuous
delivery I lied to you the delivery part
of the continuous delivery part is the
testing part so having that suite of
tests running every single time you
merge your code to that mainline branch
ensures that the branch is ready to go
at any point and so that's really the
only difference is that you're making
sure that your code is ready to deploy
at any given point and often that means
actually deploying your code to a
production like environment so you're
not actually shipping it to real users
but you are mimicking the environment
that will be working out of the real
world so what's the difference between
continuous delivery and deployment that
continuous deployment the only
difference here between continuous
delivery and continuous deployment is
instead of manually deciding what
changes to sent out into the real world
if your code passes the tests here
automatically gets deployed to users so
this is a kind of a risky way of doing
things but if you get to this point that
means your order is truly embracing this
DevOps culture truly embracing this
continuous I guess lifestyle best
so all of this is done in an effort to
reduce this feedback loop between we
want to get stuff out to users as
quickly as possible so they can give us
feedback on whether they like it whether
they don't what's working what isn't so
these can kind of be viewed as different
steps the spectrum of how continuous you
actually are developing so I hope you've
enjoyed this series and hope you've come
out a little bit more enlightened about
what being continuous really is thanks
for watching